so over the last 48 hours we've had a
stunning contrast between the man who is
currently president of the United States
and the man that wants to be President
of the United States and I'm talking of
course about Trump and Joe Biden Donald
Trump as I've already told you to some
degree a sat in the White House at one
point in the basement bunker at another
point he went down to Florida to give a
speech about Elon Musk's success with
NASA in launching the Falcon 9 rocket
with the Dragon spacecraft to bring two
astronauts to the space station and
Donald Trump essentially spent the
weekend tweeting attacking the motives
of protesters threatening to release
vicious dogs against protesters and
generally escalating tensions meanwhile
Joe Biden who is four years Trump's
senior went out and wearing a mask
talked to actual protesters about what's
going on why they are protesting and all
of these relevant issues in society
today took pictures with people while
tweeting conciliatory and understanding
things rather than threatening people
with releasing the hounds essentially
this the contrast could not be more
stark at this point no national address
from Trump meant to reduce tensions and
bring people together instead a weekend
of tweets about vicious dogs an ominous
weapons and the Secret Service is going
to go after people tweets talking about
we're gonna make an Tifa a terrorist
organization and then Trump being rushed
on Friday
to the underground bunker used to
protect presidents during terrorist
attacks below the White House even China
goading from foreign ministry spokesman
Li Jie and Xiao urged the United States
to eliminate racial discrimination and
protect the lawful rights of minorities
huija jean editor of the nationalist
tabloid Global Times telling Donald
Trump mr. president don't go hide behind
The Secret Service now that's Trump then
you have Biden Biden who you don't have
to like you don't have
see is a progressive because he's not
Joe Biden went and met with protesters
tweeted conciliatory messages you don't
have to love Biden to understand the
difference between these two men you
don't have to see Biden as a progressive
because as I said he's not to realize
that the world is laughing at us and we
would be better off if they stopped and
replacing Donald Trump with Biden is the
option we have five months from now and
I will be doing everything I can to make
sure that that replacement takes place
Trump tweeting about releasing the
hounds on protesters Joe Biden tweeting
quote we are a nation in pain right now
but we must not allow this pain to
destroy us as president I will help lead
this conversation and more importantly I
will listen just as I did today visiting
the site of last night's protest in
Wilmington Biden publishing a five
minute video discussing what we are
seeing with police and George Floyd in
some detail adding quote we are a
country with an open wound none of us
can turn away none of us can be silent
none of us any longer can hear those
words I can't breathe and do nothing we
must commit as a nation to pursue
justice with every ounce of our being
and most importantly maybe Joe Biden not
hanging out in a bow and a bunker or in
his basement in Delaware but just going
out and talking to protesters were
showing some of that video now so listen
am I saying Joe Biden is the be-all
end-all on criminal justice reform of
course not Joe Biden sponsored the 1994
crime bill that was so destructive
Bernie Sanders also voted for it by the
way and there is no doubt that not
enough was done during Barack Obama's
administration of which Biden was a part
on criminal justice but this is
comparing apples to bicycles it's
comparing apples to trash when it comes
to Biden and Trump and the leadership
deficit that we're experiencing right
now it's a tragedy and the optics of
Trump tweeting from a White House bunker
while Joe Biden is kneeling with
protesters this isn't good for Trump it
shouldn't be good for Trump
Biden of course would not get everything
right as president but at least he would
bring back something that looks and
feels like leadership and like a man
connected to what's happening in the
country rather than a guy who will
literally sit in his basement tweeting
adjutants is instigated by virtue of his
every tweet if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blink it's blink Isleta consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blink Asst blink east
has books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about 8 bucks a month and you get the
entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video